seit gerade mal einem jahr sprudelt
dieser brunnen in der biberacher
altstadt er wurde für satte 20.000 euro
gebaut aber das gute stück halten viele
bürger für hässlich und völlig fehl am
platz jetzt hat die stadt beschlossen
dass der nagelneue brunnen wieder
wegkommt schön finde ich nichts und es
ist kein großer verlust wenn du wieder
wegkommt allerdings wenig schade um die
steuergelder verschwendet werden
es passt nicht hierher ist einfach nicht
passend ist nichts historisches gar
nichts und der platz hat eigentlich wie
andere bedeutung
also nach einem jahren brunnen weg zu
machen finde ich jetzt schon ein
bisschen heftig weil die das geld hätten
vielleicht dann vorher auch anders
anlegen können der historische schaden
hof in biberach wird vor einigen jahren
umgestaltet dafür muss auch ein neuer
brunnen er vorher stand an der stelle
ein historischer druck nun soll etwas
zum spielen und planschen für die
kleinen her
ein fachbüro wird beauftragt und
professoren beurteilen die entwürfe als
die biberacher dann dieses ergebnis
sehen schlagen viele die hände überm
kopf zusammen
trotzdem bilder baubürgermeister im
biberacher rathaus von einem schweren
planungsfehler nichts wissen ich würde
sagen fehlerhafte planung würde ich
nicht sagen
vielleicht die planung an den geschmacks
vorstellungen vieler menschen vorbei das
würde ich sagen passt ja und jetzt
werden wir aufgefordert das zu ändern
aber das brunnen desaster kostet die
stadt doch einen haufen geld muss klar
sagen lieber seine wohlhabende stadt
heißt wir können uns das leisten und
dann rettet auch entsprechend umgesetzt
das sei nicht der hintergrund wenn man
jetzt finanziell größte probleme hätte
würde diese diskussion nicht stattfinden
aha während viele städte in deutschland
kaum wissen wie sie das wasser für ihre
brunnen bezahlen sollen gönnt sich
biberach dient schnell abriss eines
brandneuen bauwerks dafür nannte worte
da kann ich nur sagen wenn es um esel zu
wohl wird geht aufs glatteis tanzen und
das ist ja so geld spielt hat scheinbar
keine rolle ihr bios wahrscheinlich sie
mir wirklich zu reich als dass man noch
geschmack haben könnte
ja ich denke dass sich die stadt bebra
schon besser mit den bürgern absprechen
was wollen wir überhaupt wieder bewohner
der stadt bebra und genau das wird jetzt
auch passieren denn die brunnen
geschichte ist noch nicht zu ende
die bürger sollen nun vorschläge für ein
neues wasserspiel einreichen eines wird
dann gebaut was das zusätzlich kosten
wird keine ahnung zumindest bleibt die
hoffnung dass sich die stadt mit ihrem
nächsten brunnen nicht wieder nasse füße
holt